[Music]
hey you guys what's up
it's monday yeah i gotta go out tonight
yeah so we might be a little hungover
tomorrow but yeah it'll be okay
i'm drinking the booze i was drinking
last night i [ __ ] fell asleep the
[ __ ] was on the [ __ ] nightstand i'm
still drinking
it's like well you can't waste it oh i
didn't realize that was booze i thought
it was just like lemonade or something
[Laughter]
no it's uh okay that was the cocktail
last night yeah pineapple and vodka well
man where's mine
[Laughter]
yeah i did i drank mine while i was
watching uh watching some riff tracks
last night
all right so we're gonna start this one
you already got one naysayer in the
comment section saying this movie's joke
dude that's perry is saying that you
know what to talk about
yeah this was actually a really
entertaining movie i don't know if i
don't remember if i saw this one back in
the day i'm sure i probably did because
i kind of saw everything but 70s classic
yeah it's from 1978 capricorn one
practical effects this is the only movie
i know of where they got a dude hanging
on the [ __ ] side of the [ __ ]
biplane tele telly savalas flying it and
they actually hit the airplane with a
helicopter and that's just real
well i was watching something about this
earlier i mean obviously when they do
the close-ups of the kind of airplane
the you know the crop dusting airplane
being chased by the helicopters
when they do the close-ups those are
obviously optical shots although they
look pretty good like for optical but
um they actually talked to the guy that
flew the plane like the stunt guy yeah
uh and he said that this was i think he
said like during his whole career this
was the most dangerous
uh stunt like you know airplane stunt
that he'd ever done and it shows like if
you uh
if you watch the movie because we're
sitting there watching that going but
that looks real that doesn't you know
what i mean i think that doesn't look
like [ __ ] i think it was real
i think they just said it was fake so
they could get away with it
nobody said it was fake
no i'm talking about the close-up shots
where the [ __ ] oh no you no you
helicopter well those i wasn't talking
about that i was talking about the ones
where like uh james brolin was like
hanging on the wing like stuff like that
those are optical because you can see
around the edges
no but when that helicopter skid hits
the top of that airplane that was real
yeah i'm pretty sure that was real yeah
i mean everything in that like all the
airplane stuff looked real and they did
um
too the there's one like a famous kind
of car chase in it like with elliot
gould in the car where it's kind of
going through all the things and i think
they use that footage in a bunch of
other movies as well which you know
isn't that budget minded i was air
assault qualified worked with a lot of
[ __ ] helicopters out on op311 then
mfo mission up in egypt and we were
doing sling loads and [ __ ] off at uh-1
huey's
and people would think that it was
that a helicopter a hovering helicopter
would be like they're very mighty of
course i mean they can lift [ __ ]
hellacious [ __ ] weight but if it's
just hovering you can just grab that
skid and pull that helicopter
you wouldn't think you could but you can
because he's just trying to remain
neutral and he's remaining neutral it's
kind of weightless like it doesn't have
much mass it doesn't take much to offset
that helicopter now if he was to to hit
the controls of course it would just
take off
but if he's trying to just hover you
could and that's the same thing with
those airplanes when he was hovering
above that airplane the relative speed
wasn't very
fast you know and the masses involved
are lifting bodies so they'll bump off
each other when i saw that [ __ ] happen i
was like man that was a real impact
i was i was impressed they'd never do
that today
yeah because probably people would get
killed
hit an airplane with a helicopter
they're like we're just [ __ ] we're
just gonna do it it's the 70s yeah we
don't give a [ __ ] yeah and then you got
[ __ ]
greco-american legend telly savalas
flying that [ __ ] that was a real man
there telly although he didn't he didn't
really fly the plane they said he was
actually like terrified of flying yeah
yeah so he's like [ __ ] out i don't
know that i'm just gonna pretend he was
a mad man
he was a mad lad in real life though
[ __ ] he was he was definitely a good
dude everybody loved him he was the [ __ ]
macho [ __ ] he was an ass grabber
he's like he's watching around here well
yeah yeah
um
yeah surprising hey hey who loves you
baby he didn't get amazed who loves you
baby but yeah you can get with murder
though the well the thing about it well
he's great in this it's like it's not a
huge part he just kind of like it's
almost kind of like a it's not i want to
say it's like a glorified cameo but he's
only like in a scene near the end
it's kind of because karen black is in
this too yeah sexy ass karen black even
though she also just has she's like a
special appearance by yeah kind of thing
she's still got that slightly cross-eyed
look though she's [ __ ] hot i don't
know what it was got a great [ __ ]
disney cartoon profile and everything
with a little [ __ ]
nose bridge that goes in
they knew they knew what they were doing
when they cast in her
louis said oj's on this one right yeah
oj when he had a good reputation
yeah although it's well it's funny
because this wasn't his first acting
role he was in towering inferno yeah
prior to this i remember that one and uh
yeah so i guess like he was recommended
to be in this movie and uh peter hiams
who wrote and directed it he was kind of
like i don't know i saw the towering
inferno and he just wasn't that good an
actor um but he kind of came around like
he was like he was all right in this
he's barely in it i mean to be honest
with you he has some lines though he has
like a handful of lines and he doesn't
but he's not like a main character he
kind of had that kind of an all-american
[ __ ] vibe to him you know of course
you know when oj first appeared he was a
football hero and and he just had kind
of a real good guy image you know what i
mean he was kind of like uh i don't know
yeah how'd that work out
[Laughter]
but he was kind of like uh
i don't know
kind of like the black steve austin or
something
what was that guy's name [ __ ]
played steve austin
back in the back in the day i don't know
i'll think of it in a minute i can't
yeah he was on the [ __ ] evil dead
series and played ash's death yeah i
know i just can't remember i just can't
remember his name right now because i
was kind of i was reading comments and i
was trying to i was thinking about this
movie so
um lee majors b majors that's right
that's right oj was kind of like the
black lee majors back in the 70s
they were kind of like on par certain
ways he kind of all-american hero
[ __ ] all-american type dude
square-jawed [ __ ] you know so
they were putting him in movies he did a
lot of commercials i remember him as a
kid
yeah and he just had like a
squeaky clean all-american hero image
until that fateful day
but you know well
rob says piece of trivia elliott gould
was married to barbara streisand before
james brolin ooh
so we have two okay so what was the
timeline on this have they
was one of them married to her at this
point like in 1978 so they're working on
the same movie together it's just like
that have been really fun yeah and james
brolin's in this if you know who that is
because that's the dude from andy velhor
yeah do with a beard played lutz played
mr lutz and he's carries the movie he's
kind of like the main character in it
yeah well kind of like how whole yeah
how holbrook
has like a really big part yeah he's in
it right but um
interestingly i don't know if you know
this but the guy that wrote and directed
this uh peter hiams yeah he also made
outland with sean come on the movie do
you remember that one uh he made 2010.
yeah i like that one also uh he made a
couple jean-claude van damme movies
sudden death and time cop actually
sudden death was good time cop was a
missed opportunity it was one of the
better vet damn movies and he made uh
end of days
okay yeah same guy that made end of days
ended days end of days that was the one
with uh arnold schwarzenegger i'm pretty
sure that was not wrong
he made the relic too which was that it
was corny as [ __ ] it was i think i saw
that in the theater yeah i didn't love
it well like the worst arnold
schwarzenegger movies if you ask me well
yeah
but uh so yeah so peter hiams actually
got the idea for this way back in 1972
and the idea that he had i guess he
started out working in tv and he worked
at cbs
and he was actually working at cbs when
they had the when they did the moon
landing
and he's like so it occurred to him he's
like you know it's this really big you
know momentous thing that happened in
history like landing on the moon
and really the only witnesses to it that
we have other than the dudes that
actually did it were tv cameras and he's
like wow that would be like super easy
to fake because he was thinking to
himself and he actually there's a quote
and it's even on the wikipedia page
where he says something like well you
know my parents generation believed
everything that they saw in the
newspapers and we knew that that's
[ __ ] and he's like in my generation
kind of believed everything they saw on
tv and we also found out that was
[ __ ] so he's like so i got really
interested
in
making a movie about
what if not necessarily the moon landing
being faked but something else like that
what if there was something momentous
like that that was faked because you
know you could do it all through tv and
it's interesting because he wrote the
movie
and nobody wanted to make it
until watergate happened and then
suddenly everybody was like yeah this
sounds like a plot something like that
actually
i don't know well the thing about it
it's like if you watch the movie it's
not
super believable like the way you go
about it but it's still like
entertaining
it's an action movie it's an action
adventure
kind of
movie with government intrigue and
like uh
nowadays you'd call it conspiracy theory
but so a lot of the [ __ ] was plausible
the reaction public reactions and how
governments [ __ ] how they would react
to certain things kind of plausible
uh just interesting it's
um and it's it and it's done in a 1970s
motif which to me i think it ages well
somebody's asking somebody was saying
that they saw it many times when they
were kids and it probably doesn't hold
up today it holds up well as
entertainment
yeah it was actually like way more
entertaining than i thought because i
don't remember if i saw this when i was
a kid if i did i probably did but i
didn't it didn't like stick with me i
saw little flashes of it but i don't
think i've ever watched the whole thing
but i was i thought it was like really
entertaining yeah i thought it was
really entertaining yeah and uh what
it's about is a group of astronauts
they're training to go to mars
and they're in the damn launch capsule
and they're just getting ready to launch
they got 20 minutes and all of a sudden
the [ __ ] somebody the other dude in the
suit opens up the hatches come on out of
there like what what it's an emergency
come on i get out of there
there's like that's what's going on and
they stick them away in a damn bus and
the [ __ ] capsule leaves without them
and then
and and they're like they trusted this
dude you know i mean they've dealt with
him for a long time he's part of the
space program but it's like the space
program cia they were they both kind of
working together
they said that look for budgetary
reasons we cannot afford
any kind of accidents
so we're going to remove
the risk well that they knew that there
was going to be because they said what
ended up happening was the contractor
that made the life support yeah system
they had like lowballed it and made like
a shitty one and they found out later so
they're like oh well it would have
failed so you guys would have died right
and we can't afford like nasa's gonna
get defunded right if we have another
[ __ ] up so we can't have another [ __ ] up
we have to have like a success so that
was probably that was plausible they
knew it was gonna happen but they just
let the astronauts go along with the
launch
they pulled them out of there in the
last minute and they had a backup plan
already in place and where they take
them as they're in this [ __ ] movie
studio and it's like a tv it's like an
old like an abandoned military base like
out in the desert yeah it's been
converted into a into a damn mars
landing field and they got the capsule
there and they we're going to reenact it
right from here and you guys are going
to be heroes we're going to like save
the space program in america you're
doing america a great service but we we
can't you fail also they threatened
their families yeah they didn't go along
with your
family and so there was all these little
they were like your families are all on
an airplane together with anything we're
about bad to happen to that airplane
yeah sure would hate something bad to
happen there's no choice
they had to go through it
and they were not happy about it and
they go through the whole thing in the
movie you're like wow this is a weird
movie then all of a sudden there's a dab
twist
when the capsule comes in for atlanta it
burns up our reentry which was uh
well wait a minute what's gonna and
there go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah those
astronauts [ __ ] break the [ __ ] out of
there because they know that they're
going to kill them
so they're going because they'll have to
yeah so then it's kind of like a big
chase sequence and they're out in the
damn desert trying to survive
and the cia or this special company
that's been hired by the cias trying to
hunt them down and kill them and
you just gotta wait to see you know i
don't want to spoil everything
but a bunch of [ __ ] happens and um
and a bunch of [ __ ] happens oh thank you
though yeah invited that was very simple
yes
but it was a good flick i enjoyed it and
i think i think we watched it for free
did we
yeah i think it's on amazon prime for
free yeah like i didn't think we had to
pay to run yeah i don't think i'd have
paid three or four dollars to see it
but it was a fun watch
yeah i had a good time with it well
because like i said all i knew about it
because like you said i said oh well
it's about i thought it was about faking
the moon landing it's actually about
faking a mars landing which is the same
difference and it's it's interesting too
because if you see some of these like
crazy conspiracy documentaries and stuff
that people make uh about faking the
moonlight like stanley kubrick fake the
moon lady they use stills from this
movie like on the cover of it and
everything i'm like do they know that
that's from capricorn one or no or do
they just like look here's proof yeah
but it's like there's some capsule and
stuff i have to say too that
i love
even though nat in this is ostensibly
like the bad guys
because they i mean people have they
have people killed and disappeared and
[ __ ] like that nasa were actually really
good sports about it and like they
they did like a consulting on the movie
and they gave them like a bunch of [ __ ]
like a bunch of uh they gave him like a
lunar lander prototype that they could
use in the movie they were just like
that's okay make us look like villains
we don't give a [ __ ] i guess it wasn't
nasa doing it though
well hal holbrook worked for nasa yeah
but i think there was like some other he
worked for other agencies too and that
was like a hired agency i think i think
it was dressed up to kind of look like
nasa but they were cia or cia contracted
company
because where the [ __ ] nasa doesn't have
attack helicopters out of blue no they
would have had to contract with somebody
but the whole thing about it was they
they had somebody behind them i think it
was nasa but they had somebody behind
them that wanted the funding to keep
going because i think was it the
president or the vice president
well no one of them didn't want to keep
the funding going they said we can't
afford going to mars and all this other
[ __ ] so they were afraid that if
they did this mars launch and it [ __ ]
up yeah then they were gonna have their
funding pulled so they were like well
this has to go ex like perfectly
no matter what so we can keep our
funding going yeah the movie i thought
the movie was awesome though it had
all-star cast from the past a lot of
legends
uh the edits good it [ __ ] pulls you
in it's pretty fast
uh it's old school practical effects
it's old school kind of dialogue and
just the way it's edited it's just
it's very nostalgic for for the 70s era
70s drama yeah the way they did things
was different uh can i say i loved
what you know what i think my favorite
thing about this movie other than that
like awesome like plane and helicopter
chase was elliot gould
i loved elliot goldenness he's like a
journalist
figures out that something maybe is
weird going on so he's kind of like
investigating and karen black is also a
journalist like a friend of his and when
they have they only have a couple scenes
together but like they're kind of like
back and forth like
it's like so so funny yeah it's like the
dialogue there is funny but elliot gold
is like a great character i mean he's
good in everything i like him and he's
like a really good character actor but i
really really like him in this like i
said the other two astronauts o.j
simpson plays one and sam waterston
plays the other one
but they don't really have a lot of
they don't have much screen time and
they don't have like a lot of character
development like you know they're just
kind of like background astronauts it's
mostly about james brolin he's like the
captain of the mission brew brew baker
uh so it's kind of like and he's the one
that has the most because the other two
astronauts when they find out that it's
like yeah we're going to fake this
those two guys are kind of like well
they don't like it but they're just kind
of like yeah but you know they're going
to kill our families as we have to go
along with it and james brolin is kind
of like nah bruh it's like this is like
you know this is like a big deal so he's
like taking the moral high ground like
we can't do this it's a lie and we're
like perpetuating you know this on the
american public and everything like that
so he's kind of more like the other two
guys are kind of more willing to go
along because they don't want their
families getting hurt as i was watching
this it
it kind of reminded me of close
encounters of the third kind there's
it
you know it wasn't spielbergian as much
as that but there's something about the
tone and the situation you know
government cover-up and space and uh
people running and trying to run from
government agencies
it kind of reminded me of close
encounters in a certain way yeah
they kind of remember how the government
in close encounters were faking the damn
toxic waste spill and having people and
it just kind of reminded me of that and
they were you know
real duplicitous and it turned out they
were hiding the damn ufo landing that
was scheduled to take place and
it was kind of like a in a weird way a
reversal of that
it's kind of like that told it out of
order
yeah just kind of the way it felt uh
just i think that i think just the the
way things were filmed to storytelling
just kind of reminded me of that yeah
because a lot of 70s movies had this had
a similar kind of like vibe to it yeah
this movie actually i think it cost less
than 5 million dollars to make
and it was actually it ended up being a
really big hit i think it was like the
biggest it because it was independently
produced
um but i think it ended up being the
biggest independent movie that year like
it was a big crowd pleaser yeah um you
know like we we're talking about those
kids well it's like the um critics were
kind of mixed on it because some said oh
you know it's good but it's like not
super believable and stuff which i get
that it's you know it's not really but
you know then some other critics said
yeah it's like super fun it's like kind
of entertainment melodrama yeah it's
just kind of like a fun kind of thing
but audiences really did uh respond to
it so you know there was that kind of
thing too but here's the funny thing
what i was gonna say oh it's one of the
best things about this movie like i said
all i knew about it was that it was
about somebody faking you know the moon
landing or mars landing or whatever i
didn't expect that to only be like the
first half that's really only the first
half of the movie
you know what i mean and then like
halfway through the movie you know the
mission ends
and then something and i was like oh i
was not expecting that and i was just
like oh [ __ ] they're in trouble now so
it was just then the second part was
like this whole kind of like them trying
to evade people that were trying to get
them and stuff i found this quote on uh
on wikipedia peter himes the writer
director
he says
this i don't know this is this is like
[ __ ] up but it's still made me laugh
he said o.j simpson was in it it was in
this movie and robert blake was in
busting which was the first movie he
that he'd made so he said i've said many
times some people have afi lifetime
achievement awards some people have
multiple oscars my bit of trivia is that
i've made films with two leading men who
were subsequently tried for the first
degree murder of their wives
so that's kind of kind of count for
something i guess
but uh yes i just thought that was kind
of i said that's [ __ ] up but i still
thought that was like kind of funny
yeah got people in the car mostly karen
rob and uh lee uh was it's just rob and
karen rob
they're talking about this movie
they just saw it recently
karen rob uh couldn't believe they
missed it at the time but they they
enjoyed it it it
kind of holds up but it's
it's 70s nostalgic charm
kind of takes you back
if you were a kid you kind of remember
the gestalt and the tone of the time and
the thinking of the time the way
the way people thought the way movies
were told
you know i i don't know how it would
appeal to a person in their 20s that
probably a lot of it probably go over
their heads
uh just you know in terms of the
nostalgia factor they wouldn't i don't
think they'd know what we were talking
about
but if you were grew up as a kid in the
70s or the 80s it's just kind of like oh
yeah i remember that guy and i remember
when movies were like this and it just
it was good i kind of feel like if
you're into like conspiracy type movies
you'd probably like it because it's like
that
you know it it doesn't necessarily you
don't necessarily have to understand
like the context or have been around in
the 70s i mean it helps obviously yeah
but this i mean the story is pretty
straightforward yeah that you know we
need funding for this and we can't [ __ ]
this up so we're gonna just pretend that
we went to mars i mean the the you know
the
the what do you call it the rocket
actually goes there so the astronauts
don't and they're as they're asking did
did teddy cevallos rock up for the movie
he's rocked up to the whole [ __ ]
thing
when you do see him he's a wild ass
flying a damn crop duster and he
picks up one of the astronauts out in
the desert
thinking that the astronaut is a [ __ ]
bank robber and that he has money and
then he's going to get like absolutely
get half the loot he doesn't realize
well the journalist keeps telling him
he's like just go pick him up it's my
friend go pick it up it's like what did
you rob a bank or something no and it's
just kind of like but then he just
assumes anyway he's like can i have to
lose he's like yeah fine yeah he could
have half the bank
and the plan he's in is a biplane it's a
crop dustin biplane and he keeps telling
elliot gold put your head down put your
head down with open cockpit and stuff so
he goes all red baron and [ __ ] [ __ ]
flying
flying low as low as you can as fast as
you can and trying to outsmart these
attack helicopters and the [ __ ]
helicopters are hitting his plane and
that what that did happen that
helicopter did hit that plane yeah like
i said the only things that are
obstacles i'm pretty sure are the
close-ups yeah i was like whoa that was
a good one
of them like in the plane but other than
that when you see the planes from far
away they're hitting each other and
stuff we're pretty sure that's right
whoever took that shot he's got the
camera he's leaning out the side door of
the chopper and i think it was an oh 58
and you see the skin that oh 58 hit dead
center of the upper wing spar that
[ __ ] biplane boom and it does it a
couple times boom boom and he starts
trying to knock that airplane down and
you can see
that pilot look in in the cockpit
looking up and yeah it was good man that
was real and there was a dude a stuntman
hanging
uh uh [ __ ] on the bottom wing on the
way again on the wingspar up against the
fuselage hanging from the wing
he's down there on the wing like a wing
walk because like a couple of those
shots like when that plane kind of goes
through that cliff and it just goes
woohoo like that i was like holy [ __ ]
look at that just they would they would
just do that with cgi nowadays yeah and
just the shadow all the wind going and
the skin and the background behind the
[ __ ] plane you just
they couldn't have faked that shot in
the 70s and gotten it to look that real
that that was a real shot of them
hitting that airplane
yeah because like i said if they done
and even the opticals in this where they
do like you know the insert shots with
you know james brolin on the wing that
they show his face and stuff that's an
optical but it looks actually really
good you can see around the edges
slightly like you usually can with that
kind of green screening kind of shot but
not as bad as like some
movies from that era actually not nearly
as bad because i had to like actually
squint to look it and it was like hd
yeah and there were some chase scenes
that were pretty good some car wrecks
there was there's some action in it yeah
where those cars were chasing well no
what happened was that um elliot gould's
character call field his name was he was
a reporter and um he was uh so he's in
his car and then he was like he had a
friend that worked at nasa
that
was kind of like well he noticed that
something was wrong he's like why is the
tv stuff like from mars coming in faster
than the telemetry yeah information he's
like that shouldn't happen and he got
suspicious because he kept reporting it
to like the higher ups and they're just
like oh you know that console is just
broken don't worry about it and um that
friend like disappears yeah and they do
that was like one of the creepiest
scenes like i said this is not
completely believable but it's still
like kind of creepy that friend
disappears and elliot gold is like where
the [ __ ] did he go and he goes to that
dude's apartment and when he gets to the
apartment there's this woman living
there and she's like i've been living
here for however and he goes in and it's
all different it's all like redecorated
and it's like the the lease still has
that woman's name on it and he's just
kind of like okay now this is not right
and then like he gets in his car and
somebody's [ __ ] with his car like cut
the brake lines or
you know and [ __ ] like that so the car
just keeps like speeding up and he can't
stop it and it goes off a bridge and
it's like all this other kind of crazy
stuff that's a really really great scene
too that whole
that you know but it's it's fun it's
like kind of like a fun
action movie conspiracy thriller type of
thing like i said you got to suspend
your disbelief but come on yeah it's you
know it's hollywood well that's
hollywood it's american movie from the
70s it's just trying to give you
something to watch yeah just just have a
good time with it and like i said it
really did seem like audiences responded
really really well to this this is like
the the the highest grossing independent
film that year yeah uh this one and
actually peter heim's the director he
said when he went to like all the
premieres and stuff he said people like
cheered and stuff yeah like soap and
cheered this was a this was a um
this movie could easily compete with the
movies of the day and and beat movies of
the day a lot of movies of the day were
mostly dialogue based
back in the 70s most of which is
dialogue based kind of
vapid humor uh vapid [ __ ] comedies or
kind of [ __ ] lowball police movies
kind of depressing you know um so no i
could see this would have been exciting
for back in the day
yeah that's like i said i thought it was
like pretty yeah i had action sequences
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] involving planes
and cars and
spies
counterintelligence guys trying to do
spy actually
yeah community uh oh [ __ ] conspiracy
theory stuff space program it just kind
of had it all karen black sexy karen
black
even though
like i said it was supposed to be k
actually it was supposed to be candice
bergin that was supposed to give that
part but then she couldn't do it for
whatever reason
so uh yeah karen rob said i knew they
were going to do that guy in i know see
that that guy he was kind of like
well he knew that like you hey man
[ __ ] that video signal should be
coming here later where's the time delay
yeah you know
so can that that that transmitter
whatever's transmitting that is close
it's not far out in between here and
mars
and then he just kept reporting it and
then they were just kind of like nah
he trusted his chain of command
chain of command was in on it [ __ ]
knocked his ass off yep
they never did like specifically he just
disappeared and i'm like
well i know that but they never said
like exactly like where they the world
nothing the world of shadows got him
they just uh but they just made it so
but creepy enough it's like they didn't
just have him disappear they made it
like he had never never existed
that's even creepier even though like i
said much harder to do if you don't have
any close relatives or living relatives
like your parents are gone you're not
married and you don't have any clothes
they could
they could do that and it could be that
they looked into his background they're
like he's got no living relatives [ __ ]
he never existed yeah they can do it
we're just going to pretend
never born if you don't believe me then
[ __ ] there have been people that died up
in their apartments with no surviving
relatives and the body laid in there six
seven years with a damn tv going yeah
it's happened before it's sad but it has
happened like i said if you don't really
if if no one expects you to be anywhere
then you just like if you're retired or
if you don't really have any family that
you check on or happens all the time
then
it's kind of scary some of those dudes
can die in another city and they don't
he's a john doe over there and they just
throw his ass away and in other places
he never showed back up and it's just
forgotten
yeah
well it's a big world yes there's lots
of people and like i said there's if you
want to see something really alarming go
to like [ __ ] wikipedia and go to like
unidentified murder victims there's lots
there's tons of them so many it's like
so so scary and like i said it's usually
people that
i mean a lot of times it's like younger
people that you know ran away or
you know did something else like you
just can't put a name on them or
marginalized or something like that and
they went somewhere else like went to
another state or somewhere and nobody
knew them there you can't match a name
up with the body so you don't know yeah
because you don't know where they came
from yeah so you know it's even in this
day and age i mean it's easier now to
identify them but and in a situation
like that if the body disappears and you
didn't know the name then it never
happened
jenny's done whole books on them yeah
some people have just fallen through the
cracks that are not even reported
missing
so yeah once the serial killers get they
don't they're not even reported missing
yeah nobody knows they're even dead or
they haven't ever existed yeah because
like i said some of them are estranged
from their families and they live like
you know
you know several states away or
something and their family doesn't even
know
that family doesn't want to hear from
them yeah there's that too yeah
yeah louis says the 70s was the decade
for disaster movies and political
thrillers yeah yeah there were so many
of them and it's like we've really kind
of gone down the rabbit hole haven't we
yes i just been in like a 70s kind of
like we need we need to do some 70s
disaster flicks some good with like
poseidon adventure and [ __ ]
i know yeah those are still like i used
to watch this all the time every time
they were on cable thing about a
disaster the thing about a disaster
movie is the what it was what was the
the attractive quality of them back
back in the day the market liked them
because they were always an all-star
cast
yeah they always got all the [ __ ]
people everybody in it was some kind of
star celebrity there'd be 50 of them
each one of them had a bit part
and uh usually it was in some kind of a
glamorous location and a disaster would
happen there and then
it's kind of like survival adventure
uh
a lot of not really plot drift well
disaster driven not character driven
and it's just it's just a an excuse to
see all your favorite celebrities get
[ __ ] up
that's what i was gonna say it's like
it's like gee where can i i never knew i
wanted this but i'd really like to see
leslie nielsen fall into a crack in the
earth yeah you know what i mean and
here's a movie that will like
accommodate you um one of the ones that
i've seen most recently uh because they
did it on the new on the newer uh
mystery science theater that that on
netflix was avalanche yeah that had mia
pharaoh in it yeah and it had it wasn't
it wasn't a terrible movie but i mean
the the rift tracks of it was or the mst
of it was like super super fun avalanche
i think was made for tv wasn't it i it's
hard to tell with that era because a lot
of them kind of looked like that yeah
that because it became a huge glut of
[ __ ] disaster films and they got
worse as they went along really from
what i remember i kind of feel like in
the 70s there was a whole bunch of
nature run amok once yeah like kingdom
of the spiders empire of the ants food
of the gods yeah uh you know there was a
whole orca there was like a whole bunch
of them well you had jaws you got a top
jaws yeah he topped jaws with a [ __ ]
killer whale
[ __ ] man in italy i think they made like
50 bajillion rip-offs of
of jaws uh the most famous probably
being the last shark but they also did
devil fish which mst also did
but uh yeah that's
i kind of want to watch some of those
what was the what was the
the swarm i forgot about that one wasn't
the shot in that one
was the shot no the shot was in kingdom
of this planet
who was in the swarm
the one with all the bees i don't
remember they had like terrible terrible
like traveling bat shots of all the bees
because obviously i mean some of the
close-ups if i remember i haven't seen a
long time but
some of the close-ups they actually put
bees on people's faces or took dead bees
and glued them on there i don't know
airport 77. that's yeah
louis called out a good one yeah
yeah there were yeah there were like
three of them yeah and then airport 75
had karen black in that as well that's
right yeah oh man roller coaster isabel
maybe that's the next thing we should we
should do we should do 70s disaster
louis says it's airport airport 75 and
77 the holy trinity of disaster films
well that's what that's what the movie
airplane was parodying yeah specifically
like those
types of movies yeah you got me on
something there man maybe we had to go
see the airport series like i said now
i'm kind of yeah it's like why are free
for free on [ __ ] amazon they might be
we should go look in there because like
i said i'm kind of i'm kind of in on the
70s vibe now it's like i'm liking like
all the political thrillers and the
conspiracy thrillers and stuff um but i
kind of want some cheese in there too i
actually wouldn't mind re-watching orca
because i remember i remember really
liking that one
i've never seen all the president's men
and i remember that was around that time
henry fonda was in the swarm was it yeah
i knew there was like it's always like
big stars because wasn't i think
elizabeth taylor was in
empire the ants i want to say was she in
a part of the ants and she was in one of
those hey louie louie what was the
synopsis what was the situation with all
the president's men
yeah we need to we need to see that one
again too they have like a huge list of
shoes yeah there was there was i don't
think that was the spy one
yeah i can't even remember it's been oh
there's another one that came to mind
remember the china syndrome yeah gotta
see the china syndrome that had peter
fonda in it right i can't remember and
and and and elsa had jane fonda was
there in the same movie i think peter
fond of james where's the jack levitt
it's a jack lemmon and
jane fonda she's playing the news
reporter in the damn
the reactor the reactor in the nuclear
power plant was getting ready to melt
down was going to cause the china
syndrome it was kind of like uh
it's kind of like uh
it was a disaster movie but it's about
nuclear power i remember liking it
yeah i don't even i don't remember if i
saw that like i said i'm sure i saw all
these because they used to be on cable
like all the time
um but i don't remember oh somebody said
we should we need to see a clute as well
i don't remember that which i saw that
one a long time ago too i remember that
one being good i know that one i
remember that one being good that had
jane fonda in it i'm pretty sure okay uh
louis says it's about the watergate
scandal all the presidents met yeah
that's what i thought
yeah like i said after watergate
happened everybody's like ooh we're
going to make all these [ __ ]
conspiracy movies and [ __ ] like that
what's funny is that something like
watergate would happen today and nobody
would notice it it was only a big deal
back in the day
well because it was one of those things
well and it was a cheat the government
well i don't even know if it was just i
mean it was that like everybody kind of
points to that but then there was the
whole like vietnam war debacle and there
was all that kind of stuff going on too
where so it was almost kind of like i
don't know if it was like a slow
disintegration of
trust and authority but you know what i
mean that's another thing that's funny
is looking
vietnam [ __ ] upset them but that was
nothing really compared to the [ __ ]
two versions of iraq war in afghanistan
both of those were
probably worse not maybe not in body
count but just in corruption i think at
this point everyone's just so like
endured to it because they're just like
of course they're like yeah of course
they don't expect any better so it's
like they don't get outraged of course
they steal money of course i think
that's what it is everyone's just so
cynical of course they they're doing
this for contract money yeah wasn't it
wasn't it i think there's a really
famous quote i think it was lily tomlin
that said it said no matter how cynical
you get you can't keep up yeah
i think she said that please correct me
if i'm wrong yeah louis says clute is a
great movie jane fonda and donald
sutherland if i remember correctly yeah
i remember that being really good i have
to like watch that one again holy crap
we have so many movies i'm saying roller
coaster one called roller coaster that's
i guess it's a disaster flick into an
amusement park
i don't think i ever saw that one did i
already see that one
huh i remember the poseidon adventure as
a kid yeah i remember seeing that one
and i remember towering inferno i
remember tyler referred but i don't
remember any details i think beside
venture had
it had uh was shelley winters in that
bunch of people would yeah
or am i thinking of the dude from
michael's navy what was his name god
also played the cabbie and uh
escaped from new york
oh yeah yeah what's that guy's name
again i can't think of it uh ernest
harness board that's right yeah he was
in it
and it's just all-star cast just
everybody's in it and you never know
who's gonna be a hero or who's gonna be
a coward
you know what i mean some go out like
chomps from what i remember
some got like chumps and some of them
will go out like heroes
you know we should i just thought of
this i don't know why i just thought of
this you know what we should do maybe
this would be too hard to do maybe we
shouldn't do it because i kind of like
keeping [ __ ] free wheeling's like
whatever we're in the mood for watching
yeah but it would be kind of neat if
like
for one week or like this month we're
gonna do all disaster movies or we're
gonna do all you know like for the
matinee not for the other [ __ ] but like
i said maybe that would be too difficult
and we get sick of them after a while
we just do them as they come yeah
because normally we don't like really
the matinees we don't really plan them
ahead all that much
um we're usually just kind of like what
do we feel like watching
a new thing or an old thing or something
or somebody sends us one and we're like
oh we should watch this and like talk
about that
um so we don't so i kind of feel like
i don't know maybe maybe we won't do
that because that requires too much
planning yeah and i kind of like to be
able to just vibe yeah with whatever i
feel like watching
we'll give you some disaster flicks
yeah because now i'm kind of like no i'm
kind of like yeah i kind of want to
watch some like cheesy ass 70s disaster
yes okay i could get into that 70s had
some [ __ ] good
storytelling in it and they're like can
we please watch orca
and it had some cheap
some of the [ __ ] was cheesy yeah but it
was still good you know for what i
remember
it's gonna go
we've been watching the 70s recently and
it's satisfying one thing about 70s
movies is that
the storytelling is very easy to follow
it's it's not very artistic it's just
kind of straightforward well it depends
on
what director you're talking about but
in general it's just kind of
everything's very normal
nothing's real special or ultra fancy
they're not really into that
uh louis says i think they filmed some
scenes of roller coaster at magic
mountain okay yeah probably did i don't
think i've ever seen it it's probably
colossus
although like i said if i'm watching it
because you know when i was a kid you
know my dad worked for cablevision so we
had like all the cable channels like
from pretty much when they started
um so when i was little we just kind of
said and my parents didn't really care
like what we watched so we could watch
like horror movies or whatever so you
know me and my brother would just kind
of like sit around and like watch
whatever was on you know what i mean
disaster movies horror movies
comedies whatever so it's like we saw so
i kind of feel like over the years i
ended up kind of seeing everything yeah
you know in one context or another
i just remember a lot of 70s movies that
i i kind of touched on when i was a kid
that i want to go back and see if they
stand up you know what i mean
if i remember them accurately
yeah because sometimes you know like
like i said sometimes you you saw movies
from back then and you're like man that
was awesome but then when you see it
when you're adult you're like oh my god
yeah that was awful yeah but um honestly
lately though uh i've seen movies i
think what's happened to me lately is
that i see some movies from you know
back in the 70s and i was just kind of
like mayor they didn't make much of an
impression but then when i see them
again like now i'm kind of like wow that
was really good
some of those i didn't appreciate them
back then i got some of those cop slash
detective movies i've never seen like
i've never seen bullet i need to see
bullet
we were thinking about watching that the
other day because that kind of came up
on amazon prime too
that's a famous movie i've never seen it
i think i've seen i don't know if i've
sat all the way through it but i think
i've seen it like in pieces yeah you
know what i mean
because sometimes like i said sometimes
you'd be flipping through the channels
and you would watch it for 20 minutes
and then you wander off and do something
else but i think like over time i did
end up seeing all of it just not in
order
so there was that thing isabella's
talking about an old tv disaster movie
called super train i remember it i
remember that i don't remember anything
about it but i remember the title
i remember seeing it that i did see it
it was like a big event
and i don't think it was all in one
night i think they played it over two
night period i think if i remember
correctly you said it's more 70s than
the 70s
i think i think it played in two parts
over a weekend yeah you think so yeah
there was actually a lot the 70s i kind
of feel like were the sort of the golden
era of tv movies there was a lot of
shitty ones but
there was a lot of good ones too you
know what i mean like i kind of have a
soft spot for a lot of those like tv
horror movies back then there were like
actually some really good ones last
night we watched on riff tracks we
watched uh the rifftrax version of the
guy from harlem yeah which was man that
was like some sub rudy raymore so i mean
you think the rudy raymore ones were
amateurish holy crap this one was like
but it was still like pretty funny
though like pretty entertaining yeah but
it wasn't i think it was supposed to be
entertaining i don't think was supposed
to be funny though well no i don't think
it was supposed to be yeah the rudy ray
movies were [ __ ] funny and they were
supposed to be funny yeah a lot cooler
rudy ray was cooler yeah yeah but these
ones were just kind of like man there
was just so much wood paneling and yeah
pink polyester losers how many
girlfriends has this dude got
he's got a girlfriend of every color
he's got a white one but i like that he
was kind of like low-key and he was yeah
he was [ __ ] some african president's
wife the first lady from another country
he's like hired to you know protect them
he's like a bodyguard and he's like well
i guess we're just gonna like have sex
now he's like okay yeah i guess that's
how that goes
his white girlfriend finds out but she
only gets a little bit mad
yeah she's just kind of like
and not only that but he would bring the
people he was babysitting to her
apartment yeah and be like hey can you
get out of here like so she'd have to go
to a hotel so he could find so he could
bang some other chick in her apartment
and she didn't like punch him in the
tank
i'm like oh my god girl yeah he was
flexing his power i guess
i thought it was funny this is kind of
terrible but like uh the rifftrax guys
kept calling his white girlfriend small
boob jessica simpson because she did
look exactly like jessica simpson i mean
i have to
like weirdly it's as shitty as the movie
looked like uh the quality it was
entertaining but rudy ray is better
yeah well because the rudy raymore ones
are a lot more we're a lot more batshit
crazy yeah this one's supposed to be
crazy yeah and this one kind of seemed
like just kind of a low-key shaft sort
of vibe so it didn't have anything too
nutty going on in it yeah um whereas the
rudy raymore ones were just straight up
insane yeah well he knew he he knew it
was his job to entertain you yeah so he
was [ __ ] rude i think toby has a
bunch of his movies because didn't we
watch petey wheat straw the devil's son
and i gotta see some more
[ __ ] crazy
petey reid's throw that was the [ __ ] he
was possessed by a demon
yeah that was like that was pretty
entertaining because like i said he went
like a lot more batshit crazy ideas
instead of just like
like a private investigator or whatever
okay all right so uh is that all we're
gonna we're gonna say okay so we'll be
back tomorrow afternoon
and tomorrow we're gonna be talking
about
midnight cowboy that classic because we
just watched that one as well so that's
what we're gonna be talking about okay
louie came up and says according to
wikipedia super trade was a tv series
nine episodes were made okay oh okay so
i remembered it was multi episodes i
thought it was two but yeah okay nine
now i'm gonna have to check that [ __ ]
out too
man we got so much [ __ ] we gotta catch
up on man
it's like it's bad because there's like
all this stuff from like old [ __ ] i
wanna watch and then there's like new
[ __ ] keeps coming out that i wanna see
too and i'm just like god damn it i'm
never gonna live long enough to see all
this all right we're gonna shut it down
all right so we'll be back tomorrow
talking about uh midnight cowboy thank
you everybody for dropping by and
discussing some movies with us and we'll
see you guys tomorrow